SCP-173: It’s a Sculpture so scary
that even 682 feels nervous around it.
Wanna know how to beat SCP-173 if
you ever go toe-to-foot-nub with it?
The first step is confidence and positive
thinking. Take a deep breath, smile wide,
and don’t let that big, gnarly,
concrete peanut get in your head.
Next, choose your battlefield wisely. Anywhere
dark is just going to get your head twisted like
a bottle cap. A bright space with plenty
of corners you can run around is ideal.
Of course, practice helps, too. Have
plenty of staring contests with your
friends, and play SCP Containment Breach
religiously for valuable battle simulations.
If 173 is kind enough to let you
pick the battle, we suggest limbo,
and would advise heavily against challenging it
to a game of tag, because it will definitely win.
And most important of all...Blink
one eye at a time, that way you can
always keep one eye on it at all
times, keeping it frozen in place.
Now you know how to beat SCP-173. Which
is great….because it’s right behind you!